ten dead at Santa Fe High School another
13 injured the shooter is reported to
have walked into the classroom and
shouted woohoo as he sprayed bullets
after the shooting he the police say
that he showed no emotion at all which
is the same story that we have heard
many times before
people who knew him say that they're
shocked there were no red flags seemed
like a normal guy and then this there
have been two mass shootings in our
schools in the past four months leaving
27 kids dead another 30 injured
now CNN claims that there have been 22
school shootings in 2018 and that's not
true but what is true is still very very
bad
you have to mass shootings 27 kids
killed by mass shootings in public
school in four months
see that's the whole problem with gun
control advocates when they make up or
exaggerate mass shooting statistics
school shooting statistics the first
problem is that it's to stop dishonest
the second problem is it's completely
unnecessary the actual statistics are
bad enough you know people are not
imagining things
when they say that mass shootings seem
to be happening with a much greater
frequency these days
that's not our imagination
now people my generation we we remember
you know if you're around my age then
then then of course you have a distinct
memory of Columbine I was in middle
school when that happened
and
happened and it was like unlike anything
that we had ever seen before
and then nothing like it happened again
for several years
but now you have a school shooting and
you say oh another one
top 5 deadliest mass shootings in
America have all happened in the
previous five years
okay
top 5 deadliest mass shootings in
America have happened in the last 5
years
two of the top five were committed in
the last 12 months 14 of the top 22 have
occurred in the past ten years the
deadliest mass shooting in American
history was in 2016 and then a new
deadliest mass shooting in America
happened in 2017
so yes it's bad
it's really really bad
whenever this happens people say
this isn't normal the this isn't normal
but it is normal is the point
destruction and misery
have been well they've been the norm
since the fall of man but especially
they've been the norm since the last
century close to 100 million people were
killed by communism let alone and then
there was the Holocaust many other
genocides not to mention two world wars
two nuclear bombs that was all in one
century
now we're told that that was the
previous century that was a 20th century
21st century is different and what we're
told is that we've entered into the most
peaceful time in human history but the
people who are making those declarations
as optimistic and pleasing as they sound
are simply ignoring the fact that 50
million human beings are killed by
abortion worldwide every year
and that's still going on
the world's been on a pace of
approximately 50 million abortions a
year since 1990 since at least 1990
which means that we've killed 1.4
billion people
in less than 30 years that's 20% of the
world's population 20% of the world's
population has been murdered
in less than three decades
so
most peaceful time
not even close
this is what we're living in right now
is by far the most violent and
destructive and deadliest time in human
history
and it's not even close
things are not getting better
that's what I'm trying to say
things are not getting better
they have not been getting better
they're not getting better now they
won't get better I'm sorry to tell you
this
but it's just the fact
things are getting worse in a hurry
we've simply gotten better at ignoring
how bad they are
we've gotten so good at it that we've
got this entire chunk of 50 million
humans killed every year and we could
just completely put that to the side
like it's not even happening we could
just discount that and then go around
talking about oh it's a peaceful time
it's such a peaceful time
I mean even the Santa face shooting
which just happened on Friday by the way
seems to already be forgotten by by a
lot of people it seems like the next
morning we forgot about it and I know
the Royal Wedding had a lot to do with
that the Royal Wedding which was I mean
it's such an amazing romantic story
right of a woman ditching her husband
leaving him in a dust and then going to
marry someone who's richer so it's such
an amazing romantic story right oh yes
it's so great we should all be
happily ever after right destroy your
marriage and go marry somebody else
fantastic so we moved on to that and you
know we're good at that we're good at
moving on quickly and I think we call
that resilience that's what we try to
call that we like to pretend no we're
we're resilient Americans are so
resilient there's a mass shooting and we
just move on it's not resilience its
indifference
and there is a difference between those
two things
now it should be noted that there's one
other conspicuous global trend that's
been happening across the world along
with all the bloodshed and the death and
destruction and murder over the last 100
years along with that there's been
another trend and that other trend is
secularism godlessness most countries in
the world have become increasingly
godless as the years have progressed the
West is seeing historic levels of
atheism and secularism to the point now
where there are some countries in Europe
that are predominantly majority
populated by unbelievers and these two
things are not a coincidence
the nightmare that we've lived since the
turn of the previous century has been
the direct result
of this it's been the direct result of
the world rejecting God
we have fled from God
and we have fled out into the wilderness
and what we found out here in the
wilderness in our freedom is evil and
despair and death on an unprecedented
scale
we have become an empty country and
empty people in empty world emptiness is
the thing that kind of ties all this
together the war the shootings the
genocide everything abortion ties it all
together because there's this void
that's left behind when you push God out
and as a world as a world we have pushed
God out
and we've left this giant gaping hole
and now we're struggling and fumbling to
fill it with something these school
shooters on an individual level you know
they they have this emptiness this hole
inside them they try to fill it with
something usually they turn to media and
video games this is yet another school
shooter it was an avid video game player
but I know we're not going to talk about
that it's completely totally absolutely
unrelated it's got two things have
nothing to do with one another at all of
course
because as part of our emptiness we are
so desperate to justify all of our
entertainment choices it's the only
thing we care about is just making sure
that nobody questions our entertainment
so if anyone mentions oh no we can't
talk about that
that's my entertainment how dare you now
that's gonna make me angry if you
question my entertainment the school
shootings they don't really make me that
eager but have you questioned my
entertainment that'll make me angry Matt
you
so these school shooters they they look
for something to fill the void and what
they find is not satisfying enough
usually it exasperates the problem
and so finally they explode after they
get tired of wallowing in their numbness
and their indifference they explode in
this ball of rage and destruction and as
I've said now many times I think the
main thing that they're doing why they
do this and there might be other
individual motivations we hear about
what this kid apparently had a grudge
against at least one of the girls in the
school he was rejected by her you know
ever every high school in America is
filled with boys that are rejected by
girls it's it's like the main thing that
happens to high school boys yet most of
them don't go down that path so why did
he choose that path and I think mainly
it's because of that emptiness inside
him and what he was really doing what
these school shooters mass shooters what
they're all really trying to do is
they're trying to feel something they're
trying to feel control you know they
want control over life over just this
mysterious empty thing
and that's the trajectory that the
entire human race has basically been
following
and it can't lead anywhere except
ruination
you
you know we really need a Jeremiah you
know we we need a an Old Testament like
prophet type of person in this day and
age
because in the Old Testament times they
had guys like Jeremiah they're the
prophets to come and say to them listen
you idiots do you understand why this is
happening do you understand why all
these bad things are happening because
you've rejected God
times they would put it just like that
pretty much using their own language but
just smacking people upside the head pay
attention look around you
don't act so surprised
you reject God you want to live your
your lives of sin and you're surprised
when this stuff happens don't be
surprised
we need something like that in our day
because
because what we really need
the only solution is a mass spiritual
revival and a collective return to faith
no other solution will solve anything
everything else is just kind of
reshuffling the problem
were you branding it
it's been our so that has been our
solution for the last 100 years or so is
to take a problem and just rebrand it
and call it something else so we took
the genocides of the 20th century and we
rebranded them we put them in a clinic
we call them abortion now and now we say
oh there's no more genocides we solved
the problem
hooray
so what's going to be our rebranding
solution for school shootings I don't
know
there is no solution other than
returning to God
all of us
you know stupid arrogant people
stupid arrogant
foolish people like to laugh at the idea
of thoughts and prayers in the wake of
tragedy
but thoughts and prayers really could
save us
they could
if we really had our thoughts on God
and if we really had our knees on the
ground and unceasing prayer things would
not be like this
a pious prayerful country does not kill
its own kids whether in the classroom or
the womb so yes thoughts and prayers
could change everything
and please don't come in and say well
yes Matt we need thoughts and prayers
but also action
if you say that that I'm gonna have to
suspect that you've never prayed because
you don't understand it's not necessary
to stipulate thoughts and prayers and
action if you have a deep prayer life
and your mind is focused on God then of
course you're acting action is a natural
is a natural conclusion that flows from
that foundation it's almost impossible
for a prayerful spiritual humble man or
woman not to act it's almost impossible
because a person like that has so much
grace pouring into them as a result of
their connection with God that to resist
it and not to act would require much
more effort than to simply act
so those who do not act do not pray it's
just like within your own family you
know if you're praying every day for the
spiritual and physical protection of
your own children which I certainly hope
that we all are but if you do of course
you're also taking practical steps to
protect them because that's part of the
result of the prayer and you're taking
the right steps because God is showing
you the right steps and you're doing the
right thing rather than not praying
about it and just trying to randomly
arbitrarily do things to protect your
kids when you pray first and that's the
beginning in the foundation then the
actions follow that and they're the
correct actions not just random
arbitrary actions
so the problem is not that people are
relying too much on prayer and not
enough on practical steps the problem is
the opposite
we rely entirely on so-called practical
steps and we don't rely at all on God we
don't even factor him in
so what I'm saying what I'll say again
is that if everyone in the nation had
their thoughts on God and their knees on
the ground in prayer things would get
better
guaranteed absolutely
I know that for certain our affliction
is spiritual we are a nation that is
falling more and more into the clutches
of evil and Satan and away from God and
we are still too stubborn to cry out to
God to save us so instead we cry out to
the government and doctors and
psychologists and the law and policy and
pills and the media and Hollywood and
ourselves we cry out to all of them to
save us and none of them can and we look
everywhere but up where the answer
actually lies
the key is to pray to God unceasingly to
seek his help
and to act in accordance with him
not to trust in our actions alone
but the trust in God and to act in faith
and to go to God and say what are we
supposed to do what do you want us to do
and then whatever his answer is you do
it
people who don't understand prayer and
don't have faith in it it's because they
don't do it
but if you actually pray and people who
actually pray unceasingly pray you know
they have a they have a deep prayer life
they know
they know that if they pray consistently
over a certain problem answers will
prevent present themselves and if they
go to God consistently and say God what
do you want me to do about this or that
problem an answer will come to them it
will will
100% will
God works miracles
but we have to pray
you know think about the story of
Dunkirk the store the part of the story
that the movie Dunkirk which is a movie
that I really liked but
the movie Dunkirk leaves this out but
you know we know about the movie shows
us how the Citizen Navy was mobilized to
rescue the Allied forces from the beach
what they leave out is that a Day of
Prayer was called across the country and
the British people poured into churches
and they prayed together in Mass they
prayed for a miracle and they received
it mysteriously Hitler ordered his his
troops to halt when he couldn't easily
destroyed the Allies then there was bad
weather that grounded German planes but
then the weather was miraculous II was
good when that when the when the British
needed it to be so so they get their men
off the beach the people prayed and they
acted Anna miracle occurred
and it's very possible that that miracle
not only saved those men but
saved Western civilization
God works miracles he's been doing it
since the dawn of time the dawn of time
itself was a miracle a supernatural act
that made possible all things so God
works miracles but we have to ask for
them and we have to come to him we have
to humble ourselves and pray all of us
can God stop mass shootings yes Ken he
stopped Hitler
he's healed the blind
toward the lame raised the dead he
parted the Seas he brought forth water
from a rock brought manna down from
heaven he he brought himself down from
heaven rescued us from sin so yes he
could stop mass shootings he can do
anything
we have to pray and have faith
and I'm speaking now I'm speaking now
specifically to those who believe to
those who believe in that and that or at
least claim to believin that's what 80%
of the country or more claims to believe
in God
I know this message to people who don't
believe in God to people who are atheist
to a completely secular who reject God
they hear this conversation and they
laugh and they snicker about it I'm not
talking to them okay they they are I'm
tuning them out for right now
it's not possible for me to talk about
the power of prayer to to to atheists on
the internet because they will just
laugh like children about it and so
right now I'm not talking to them
talking to people who actually pretend
to believe okay you and I those who are
left
we say we believe
why aren't we turning to God
it's only through his grace that we do
believe in the first place
so what do you think God's gonna say to
us in the end if we took all this grace
that he gave us and we wasted
he gives us this grace for a reason
so why are we acknowledging his presence
through his grace and then just leaving
it at that
okay there you are God
and then just continuing about our days
in a way where that fact has no bearing
whatsoever on our lives on how we
operate on what we do on how we think
it
we are in for a rude awakening
if everything that's been happening
around the world for the last 100 or
more years if that isn't enough to wake
us up and to make us turn back to God
even though we claimed already believe
in him if this isn't enough to make us
cling to him desperately and to turn to
him and have faith in him and to seek
his help if this isn't enough
then I think when we die we're in fray
a rough time
put it like that
so that's the solution
it's just that masked spiritual revival
you know it's as simple as that which I
know is probably not going to happen
it's the only solution
and if anywhere else we look any other
solution will be a failure so this is it
for that let's start there
thanks for watching everybody
Godspeed